We usually have the application on the
website for about two months and we go
out and do presentations at different
schools.
And sometimes that can be one
presentation and the entire school comes
as an assembly or you go from class to
class or it changes based on what
school.
But we do presentations and you know,
encourage cause the sign up.
And then about a month or so before the
trip,
we go through the selection process and
we picked the groups.
And then from then we make sure that we
have two meetings with students and
parents and then two meetings with just
students.
Um,
so that they get to know each other a
little bit before we go.
And we get to give them the history of
our organization and what we've done,
kind of what we're getting into.
And then we fly down as a group.
And in New Orleans we actually own a bus
and we just bought a second bus,
which was really exciting.
And,
um,
so when we're there,
we drive around in our buses.
But,
uh,
you know,
the first day is mostly just flying and
settling in,
but they,
the first full day we go on the levy
tour and like we start with an
orientation about the history of Nyt,
know who we've worked with,
um,
how we've gotten to where we're at.
And then we go out on the tour and
actually see the different levies and
see the different neighborhoods.
And,
uh,
we give everyone an opportunity to kind
of see with their own eyes and
understand what it is that they're
getting themselves into and the
neighborhoods that they'll be doing work
in.
And,
um,
that's a big day.
I mean,
there's no physical work really on that
day,
but it's the roughest day for everyone
because it's so emotionally and mentally
draining because most people have never
heard anything like this before or seen
anything like this before.
So that's usually how that day goes.
Um,
and every night we have a debrief and
basically the way that that works is we
bring everybody together and we sit in a
circle and we run by consensus.
And so what we do is we sit in a circle
and we have,
uh,
we have around and so every week
everybody has about one minute to speak
about their day and their feelings of
the day or any thoughts.
And once we've gotten around the whole
circle,
then we go into what we call crosstalk.
And then anybody can just kind of
interject and say whatever they want.
And I've realized that,
uh,
over time that the,
the round is really just kind of like a
warmup for the cross talk because when
people have the freedom to like really
say what they want to say without so
much time constraints,
it all breaks loose.
And you never know what's really going
to come up.
But that's where the real learning
happens.
And,
uh,
you know,
the first debrief that's of the levy
tour are usually that just are mind
blowing.
And then each day following that,
they,
they are as well there.
But they're different every day.
And I guess starting on the second day,
um,
we now work with a bunch of different
organizations and in the morning our
students do physical work,
whether it's gutting a house,
rebuilding a house,
uh,
cutting down grass and yards.
And now I'm big projects that we work on
our building community gardens.
And so we do that in the morning and
then in the afternoon we go canvasing.
And that's,
you know,
just knocking on people's doors and
speaking to residents.
And that's really the most important
part of the trip because it gives our
students a chance to speak to the people
who are actually here for Katrina and
who really lived through this and who
are dealing with these issues day to
day.
And they hear it from them and not from
us,
not from the media,
not from the government,
like directly from the people.
And you know,
we break people into pairs and they go
and it,
and it's really great on a number of
different levels.
One,
it's a primary source for our students
to really get information,
um,
to,
it means a lot to the residents because
really the,
in the ninth ward,
there's really only one house on a block
in certain areas,
you know,
some places are more populated than
others,
but you know,
a lot of it's,
it's still pretty desolate.
So to see for them to see volunteers
from New York come down just to hear
what they have to say.
And you know,
it's not about like filling out a flyer
or,
or doing a survey or anything.
It's really just to hear what they have
to say and,
and stuff like that.
So it means a lot to them.
But for us,
for our students,
it's great because,
uh,
you know,
they get a connection with a real person
down there.
And also the,
the two people that we pair up generally
probably won't have known each other
yet.
Um,
especially earlier on in the week.
And so just the experience that these
two students have walking down the
streets of New Orleans together and
knocking on homes and meeting these
amazing people.
I mean,
it bonds them forever and you know,
everybody,
like two people who would have never
ever second given each other a second
look ever before.
It could be best friends by the end of
that one day.
Well,
I guess the most,
the most dangerous work that we have is
also the most fun work.
It's gutting homes.
And we've been doing that since the very
first trip.
There are less homes,
the gut now than there used to be.
Um,
but we still,
I mean,
we just did one this February.
We're probably going to do some in April
and I mean,
would,
that means it's basically stripping a
house down to the bare bones and the
bear foundation of a house because the
homes that were lucky enough to stay
standing in New Orleans,
especially in the Ninth Ward,
still had 20 feet of water for about a
week.
So everything on the inside was
destroyed.
So we have to go in and we have to knock
down the walls,
uh,
take out the furniture,
the sinks,
electrical,
everything,
and just strip it down so that it can
then be rebuilt.
And usually everybody loves to do it
cause they get to use sledge hammers or
you know,
take their anger out on a wall or
something like that.
And you know,
people love to do that.
Um,
but it's,
it's pretty safe.
I mean,
one person in our three years has
stepped on a nail and it was our teacher
who told us to get tetanus shots and he
didn't.
So that's his fault,
but he was fine.
Um,
and,
uh,
so we've never really had a problem with
that.
And otherwise,
I guess,
you know,
with rebuilding homes,
we're always with professionals,
like people who know exactly what
they're doing,
who can handle,
who really handled the heavy machinery.
But we have worked on dry walling and
sanding and,
um,
mudding and painting and all,
all that type of stuff.
Another big part of the physical work is
mowing lawns.
And a lot of people at first are really
just not excited to do it because it's
mowing lawns.
You can do that anywhere,
I guess.
But what's the reason why it's so
important is because,
uh,
the city of New Orleans created this law
called the good neighbor law.
And it says that at this point,
if anyone's grasp reaches above 18
inches there,
then fined $500 a day by the city.
Um,
and so,
but,
but there's still about 200,000
residents of New Orleans who are,
who haven't been able to come home that
has spread out in all 50 states of the
United States in you have 6,000 of them
still in New York City right now.
There are thousands in Texas.
There's some,
even in Alaska,
I mean,
talk about culture shock being taken
from New Orleans and being relocated
there.
But,
um,
you know,
there's still everywhere but in their
homes and the government is still
mandating that they come home once a
week to mow their lawns and if they
don't,
they're going to find them,
uh,
um,
money that they can't afford.
So,
you know,
our job is really to go in there and,
uh,
mow their lawn so that these people
don't have to pay their fines.
Usually we go and mow the lawns of
people who we are in contact with,
whether they're in New Orleans or people
that we know that have,
that are still displaced.
But if we like run out of the list,
which doesn't happen very often,
but sometimes then we'll just go and
drive.
And if we see a lot that needs to be
cleared,
we clear it because we know somebody
somewhere is paying.
Some is paying $500 a day for that.
So I'm not,
even if we don't know the person
personally,
like we want to,
we know it's helping someone.
So that's another piece of the physical
work.
And then,
uh,
working on community gardens is,
is a newer project.
We,
we've just started to do that this year.
But um,
it's so important.
I mean,
it's,
it's one of the most important things
that we're doing because in,
in the lower ninth ward itself,
there's only one grocery store and it's
much more like a Bodega and they pretty
much just sell alcohol anyway.
And so the people either are resorted to
go there and buy really unhealthy food,
um,
or travel 20 miles outside of the city,
outside of the ninth ward to go to a
bigger grocery store,
which a lot of people can't afford to
do,
uh,
all the time.
So what is so important about these
community gardens is that it's creating
sources of food and healthy food,
fruits and vegetables for residents to,
um,
to eat within an,
and it's being grown within their own
community.
And it's also providing jobs for members
of the community who otherwise don't
have any,
uh,
because they can work on it.
And one major thing is that we're
working with,
we helped start there.
There also is an,
uh,
a high school in the whole lower ninth
ward anymore.
There were two and the government
actually,
uh,
tore both of them down,
one of which in the middle of our us
being in there,
uh,
gutting it.
Uh,
we had a group there and they forced the
entire group out and they knocked it
down right in front of us.
This was two years ago and it running
right now there's nothing in its place.
It's just grass.
They haven't done anything with the
land.
So it didn't really make sense to me.
But either way they tore both of the
buildings down.
So one of our projects has been,
we've helped start now the only high
school there.
It's really a technically a homeschool
but it's,
it's all that the people have right now.
And I'm one of our teachers who taught
at our school,
came down with us this past summer and
just kind of decided not to come home
and he stayed there and he helped start
the school and he's getting more and
more students every week.
And uh,
he has actually gotten the rights to the
land surrounding the school and we're
turning those into community gardens.
And right now we fund finance the school
based on our fundraisers.
But the goal is once they are really
growing fruits and vegetables,
the students will learn how to garden
and how to farm,
which is great for them,
for them to just know.
But also they can then sell those fruits
and vegetables and that money is what's
going to finance this.